ça va Jean-Baptiste on n'est pas sur le
tapis rouge
sont tous barrés et ils m'ont laissé se
tirer non c'est pas la bonne cause vous
l'avez dit on va aller à Cannes bonne
partie de la matinée allez c'est à vous
à Cannes 9e moteur et action à plus
public
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
s
bonsoir bienvenue en direct c'est à vous
en direct de c'est à vous sur le plateau
de c'est à vous inviter Alexandra Sublet
Michelin
toujours sur ce soleil qui va nous
accompagner ce matin et oui moi je suis
pas choqué par ce soleil on reçoit ce
matin non pas Julia le l'acteur mais le
réalisateur vous appelle comment mettre
maître Gims
d'ailleurs je ne m'étonne que derrière
mon siège il n'y a pas écrit mon nom et
mon prénom mais bon ça va les faire le
service public il y a 23 ans Michel vous
décrochiez votre tout premier rôle
c'était dans le marginal de Jacques doré
vous en souvenez peut-être non
si c'est faux oui non oui c'est faux on
dirait moi c'est drôle non mais vraiment
c'est là où ça me rassure
je pense qu'il faut surtout pas avoir
envie d'arrêter après un échec parce que
c'est essentiellement cet échec qui vous
pousse à chaque fois
l'école je me suis fait virer de m'embts
et tout de suite après je suis devenu
Maurice et comédien et ça vous pensez
que c'est typiquement lié à l'échec que
vous avez vécu parce que vous avez dû
développer d'autres forces c'est ça
ouais j'ai toujours eu ça au moins il a
envie de faire rire
vous avez repris les fiches d'Alessandra
Michel je te calme donc à 23 ans vous
débutiez votre carrière quelque part au
cinéma
[Rires]
je suis arrivé à Paris à quel âge à 24
ans ça va une année près dans tes films
tu es souvent nu je sais pas comment tu
fais faut que tu m'expliques mais c'est
moi
c'est un bon moment
c'est pas mal franchement c'est pas mal
tu es magnifique
ça c'est super j'ai une barre je ne peux
pas me lever parce que ce monsieur est
tout le temps malade visiblement
tordu c'est de la médecine était venu
avec un dessin un message même carrément
vas-y dis-moi ce qui a écrit prenez ma
maman Nagui s'il vous plaît
dans une trousse de théâtre en 4e et
vous êtes rendu compte que ça marchait
plutôt bien auprès des filles donc ça
vous a encouragé à persévérer non
alors ça alors ça alors monsieur était
très bien en scellé mais alors ça
vraiment ah bah c'est moi je suis celle
qui dit n'importe quoi du départ
[Rires]
qu'endroit où flash des photographes
faut tapis rouge regardez il y a aussi
les chiens et ça se passe à New York aux
États-Unis alors c'est un principe qui
est très simple regardez le soleil des
robes très jolies avec des petits
volants alors il porte les looks les
plus emblématiques des stars lors du
maître gala on en a pas il y a quelques
semaines un des rendez-vous mode de la
news aux États-Unis les Français font de
moins en moins de frais de toilette et
pour s'habiller ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux vous avez pas précis
es studio qui apparaît manuel dit encore
frais de toilette en 2023
de toilettes effectivement une tendance
originaire de New York qui en dit long
sur le harcèlement dans les transports
dans des vidéos vu des millions de fois
sur Tik Tok de nombreuses femmes
montrent comment elles couvrent leur
tenue courte avec un vêtement ample
baptisé Subway shirt cela signifie
t-shirt ou chemise de métro en français
malgré la chaleur ses accessoires XXL
seraient un mal nécessaire pour diminuer
les risques de harcèlement sexuel lors
des trajets quotidiens de basket la
surchaussures tout va bien se passer
[Musique]
je n'en mets pas cette paire de basket
montante à la semelle assez folle et
signé Carole Christiane food et elle
coûte elle coûte de l'argent elle a 2044
euros sur Tik Tok le hashtag
comptabilise plus de 4 millions de vues
c'est dire la résonance de ce phénomène
que c'est parisiennes connaissent bien
je réfléchis toujours en fonction de
quelle ligne de métro je vais prendre je
vais avoir tendance à mettre des jeans
des pantalons je vais aussi avoir
tendance à fermer mon manteau je sors
pas en mini-jupe quand je prends le
métro on fait des chenilles dans des
soirées pardon
bonsoir après l'émission non il y a rien
de débrider à faire une chenille c'est
très sage de faire une chenille on en
fera une d'ici là surtout à 4h30 du
matin tout est normal
petit dérapage de Patrick les femmes à
faire attention au lieu d'inciter les
hommes à ne pas les agresser c'est à
dire qu'en fait ça fait porter la
responsabilité de la protection sur les
femmes alors que prêt à la société aux
mentalités d'évoluer
100% des femmes qui prennent les
transports en commun ont déjà fait les
frais au moins une fois dans leur vie de
harcèlement sexiste ou sexuel ce sont
les chiffres d'une étude réalisée par le
Haut Conseil à l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes un chiffre qui date
de 2015 un autre chiffre que j'ai trouvé
très édifiant c'est que une française
sur deux quasiment et bah explique
qu'elle change de tenue ou qu'elle va
adapter cette tenue lorsqu'elle prend
les transports en commun pour éviter le
harcèlement monsieur le psychiatre c'est
quoi la fascination c'est quoi cette
fascination pour les mauvais garçons à
10 ans que c'est une
autre pardon Je te demande pardon le mec
répond à tous des questions
[Applaudissements]
ça va ça va ou quoi Brest
pardon pardon Cannes Cannes je viens de
faire ce qu'on appelle dans le jargon
une Aya Nakamura hier elle était en
concert à Lyon
[Applaudissements]
moi Céline ce soir je vous amène au
Moyen-Âge on va festoyer entre coqueré
et Jean teddam suivez-moi je te laisse
éclate-toi Nicolas merci tu ne pouvais
pas ne pas être sur les chemins de
traversement
impossible surtout pour un cachet de
4000 euros merci
excusée mais quelques minutes plus tard
[Applaudissements]